[Music]
what's shake and reject nation and sir
Boyd John Humphrey coming at you with a
little bit of a reaction I was on the
trending page earlier and I saw that
there is a trailer up for Poppy's new
YouTube read show and I was first
introduced to poppy last year I think
back when I was still working at the old
Blum house.com one of our writers ran if
what's up Brandon four enters ran an
article about poppy that blew my mind
her YouTube videos are pretty kooky say
hello to your neighbor her music is
pretty quirky and now she's got her own
YouTube read show so I am very excited
to see what on earth this might look
like come join me
[Music]
if you just let us help you oh is that a
movie is that what that is it comes out
today so I guess this is the pilot that
they're teasing right now there's it's
ostensibly going to be a series but as
of yet there is no date for any further
episodes just going off this trailer
alone it's certainly enticing me towards
YouTube read more than a lot of other
things haven't I guess but um you know
I'd get it for Vsauce this trailer here
reads more like a short film or
something than a series but it certainly
looks surreal and whimsical just in line
with what poppy is to use like there's a
whole lot of different stuff going on
I'm a little curious as to what they're
gonna do with reality I can't imagine
that this isn't gonna be super weird and
super meta and that kind of thing
appeals to me in general because as much
as a poppy video makes me squirm I also
love watching them so I really hope that
this show kinda delivers on that I mean
it's certainly fun to see Sam Levine in
there he's really killing it in the new
media space these days it looks like
this could also bring in a more overt
sense of humor maybe especially with
this weird will make everything cute and
happy
ooh this is a sinister creepy weird cute
meta perhaps I don't know there's
there's a lot that comes to mind looking
at this but uh I don't know if I'm
actually read but I would like to see
this first episode so yeah yeah yeah I'm
poppin what did you guys think are you
guys champing at the bit to see this
have you seen it already hit us up in
the comments share your thoughts and as
always you can subscribe to the real
rejects click that notification bell to
get a little notified every time a
review or a video is out
you can join us over on the Stardust app
link in the description box follow us
first over there and come check out our
patreon we're doing full-length TV show
reactions full-length stuff music videos
behind the scenes all kinds of craziness
it's a lot of fun over there come join
us Cheers